is 1925 in chicago the windy city you're
al capone also known as scarface a
nickname for a scar that you hate you
got three noticeable scars on your cheek
while working as a bouncer at a bar
called harvard inn one that you tried to
hit on a girl a few times without any
success before finally just telling her
that her butt looked great unfortunately
for you her brother was nearby and
overheard your comments he came rushing
to his sister's honor by slashing open
your cheek
from the rest of your life you tell
people that you got the scar in world
war 1 even though you never served you
also made the habit of hiding the left
side of your face in photographs at the
young age of 26 you were about to be
handed control of the multi-million
dollar chicago outfit gang an operation
worth around 120 million dollars a year
in liquor prostitution and gambling a
gang the size of a medium corporation
and ran just like a business and luckily
for you the great depression didn't hit
yet and prohibition the banning of
alcohol was in its prime
it was the opportunity of a lifetime to
build a fortune fighting against an
unjust law to satisfy people's thirst in
your mind you are gonna be chicago's
saver
1925 marked the beginning of al capone's
sixth year reign as the king of
bootlegging a journey that would take
you to the top of the criminal
underworld with an equally fast fall to
the bottom
[Music]
alphonse gabriel capone was born in 1899
and he quickly adopted the nickname al
capone was raised with eight siblings in
brooklyn his parents slowly moved on to
safer neighborhoods throughout the years
as they could afford it but it didn't
help because by the time he was eight
years old he already had a reputation as
being a tough guy because of his
uncontrollable temper and his large bill
from an early age even though he
maintained pretty good grades mostly
bees he dropped out of school by age 14.
another student has stolen his lunch he
disrupted the entire class to demand the
kid return it the teacher made the
mistake of trying to punish capone for
the outburst so he hit the teacher in
the face and walked out the door to
never return again even though it was
the end of his formal schooling it was
just the beginning of his education in
the streets after dropping out he worked
out a few different normal jobs at a
candy store a bowling alley a printing
plant around this time people described
him as a good boy who always brought his
paycheck home to his mother but his good
voice status didn't last long capone
joins the 40 thieves junior gang and
soon his impressive criminal potential
catches the attention of a high-wrecking
mobster named johnny torrillo tario was
successful fancy suave all the qualities
that impressed capone to figure out
which kids were trustworthy tario would
give them a little test he would invite
them in for an interview and when they
arrived nobody would be there but stacks
of money would be piled up on the table
toriel wanted to see who would steal
from him when nobody was watching and
capone passed the test with flying
colors and this kicks off a legendary
professional relationship together in
1918 capone married mary colin the woman
he would end up spending the rest of his
life with and that same year he welcomed
his one and only son now 19 years old
with a wife and baby he realized that
the fastest route to being rich was with
his mentor to rio but toriel decided to
move to chicago since the market has so
much more potential
in 1919 toriel finally invited capone to
join him in the windy city so capone
packs his bags and moves to the city
that would soon give him everything
[Music]
one of the main sources used for this
video was a book called al capone his
life legacy and legend books like this
are a great way to learn from the
mistakes and successes of others but
reading takes a lot of dedicated time
that is where audible comes in the
world's largest audiobook platform that
is constantly getting bigger basically
any major audio book you will want to
listen to is on there i've been using
audible regularly for the past 4 years
which is really crazy to think about so
many audiobooks i've listened to on
audible have completely changed my life
so i can't recommend audible enough plus
they have podcast guided wellness
programs comedy and exclusive audible
originals what i love about audible is
that it makes it easy to listen whenever
and wherever you want i listen to it in
the gym on planes in my car and it helps
me take back some of the time i would
have lost doing those things and instead
use that time to learn as a member you
get to keep one title per month from
their entire catalog including new
releases and best sellers you'll also
have full access to audible's growing
collection to download or stream
whenever you want and you can try it out
before committing because new members
get 30 days of audible for free again i
can't recommend audible enough if you
haven't tried it yet get 30 days of
audible for free by pausing the video
and going to audible.com jaketran or
text jake trent to 500-500 that's
audible.com jaytram with the link below
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video
you started off small in chicago
managing a few brothels here and there
even though you have a bad habit of
being a frequent customer to set bratos
you're still considered great at your
job in 1920 torrio takes over the
chicago outfit gang after the former
leader was murdered a crime that
everyone believes you helped orchestrate
but nobody could ever prove it being
suspected of murders without convictions
would be a lifelong trend for you by the
next year you're promoted and moved to
toriel's headquarters rising through the
ranks just like you intended and then
the opportunity of a lifetime arrived
prohibition
100 years ago the 18th amendment banning
the manufacture sale and transportation
of alcoholic beverages came into force
in the united states prohibition led to
social changes that would help define
the roaring twenties and ushered in an
era of speakeasies bootleggers and
organized crime changing a law doesn't
change human nature especially people's
desire for alcohol so after the ban
passed there was an instant black market
demand for alcohol and organized crime
groups like the chicago outfit were more
than happy to meet this demand with the
us's right-hand man toriel starts
flooding chicago's downtown and
southside with all the alcohol they
could possibly want along the way toriel
makes deals with other local gangs to
avoid drama and keep the peace things
were going really well for you in the
mob everyone was making money but then
the chicago beer wars begin a very funny
name between the city's gangs in 1922
and violence surges through the streets
for the next four years gang shootouts
became the norm in chicago 475 mobsters
were killed by cops or other gangsters
during this time all of that brutality
climaxes in 1924 after an attempted hit
on you and toriel torrio decided it was
time to retire leaving room for a new
boss to step into his place
[Music]
so now you are in charge of a gang with
a weekly payroll of 4 million in today's
money along with a fast salary for
yourself
you wear custom-made suits in colors
like yellow or lavender you wear
flashing jewelry and indulging gourmet
foods and you always keep a pocket full
of cash to give out to people you like
or pity and when people ask you how you
made your wealth you simply reply i am
just a businessman or i am just
satisfying a public demand al capone was
considered a modern day robin hood going
around the powers that be to give people
what they wanted and he was quickly
becoming a celebrity he was a very nice
person
as as to know him you know
and what they said so many tri he never
did anything it was his people that did
it
like his men that he had or whatever
do this dirty work
but this kind of notoriety is a problem
for a mob boss when toriel turned over
the outfit to you he said it was because
he was getting too prominent for his own
good now the spotlight that was once
onto rio was directly pointed at you you
were the target now the fear of being
killed leads you to taking some drastic
safety precautions you drive around in a
7-ton bulletproof armored catalyst sedan
with a rear reynold especially designed
to be lowered so a machine gun could
shoot through it for drive-bys you never
went anywhere alone and have more
security than the current president
calvin coolidge another way you
protected yourself was by manipulating
the media like in 1927 when a mobster's
body was found tortured frozen and
dumped you knew you would be the first
suspect so you invited the press to your
house wearing a pink apron and slippers
you say hello and invited them in for a
sit down dinner with some nice wine next
thing you know headlines were saying
what a good kind family man capone was
you had politicians and half the city's
policemen under your pay and everything
seemed like it was going perfectly
[Music]
february 14 1929 valentine's day after
years of tension you're ready to
eliminate bugs warren the leader of a
competing gang called the north side
gang so on this cold thursday morning
you have four gunmen disguise themselves
as police officers and reign morin's
headquarters the fake police line up the
victims against the wall before opening
fire on them with machine guns and
shotguns ironically morris shows up late
that day and isn't one of the seven
people murdered in broad daylights the
public is outraged at the violence in
their backyard even though you always
said you were just a businessman and a
good guy this brutal act shatters that
illusion al capone was now public enemy
number one and now the system was coming
after you previously capone wasn't
charged with any of the murders he
ordered because everyone was too scared
to talk and with prohibition winding
down prosecutors thought it would be
difficult to crack down on you for
bootlegging charges that's when a former
u.s assistant attorney general made a
suggestion why not look into capone's
finances and taxes it's common knowledge
that you were rolling in cash by this
time you're 30 years old with a net
worth of around half a billion dollars
in today's money yet for all these
riches capone has never filed taxes now
that's a prosecutable offense so members
of the outfits start going down for tax
evasion building up to their main target
capone and in 1931 capone was officially
charged with 22 counts of income tax
evasion claiming that capone owed over
215 000 in taxes on an income of 1.4
million dollars a number that many
people think is very underestimated in
the end al capone was sent to 11 years
in prison with a 50 000 fine
[Music]
capone was shipped off to a federal
prison in atlanta to begin his 11 year
sentence during the initial medical exam
capone was diagnosed with neurosyphilis
something he picked up at the brothels
for all these years it went untreated
and now it was confirmed to be in his
brain his judgment was declining and his
temper was getting worse from the
disease making prison even more
difficult after two years he was
transferred to a new prison reserved for
only america's worst criminals alcatraz
at alcatraz he got by without too many
issues even starting a banner alcatraz
called the rock islanders but by 1938
syphilis was really taking a toll on his
body headlines around the country read
capone goes insane in jail in 1939
capone was released from prison for a
combination of good behavior and rapidly
declining health doctors determined he
had the mental age of a 70 year old even
though he was only 40. capone spent his
last years living under his loyal wife's
care spending most of his days in
pajamas and having imaginary
conversations with people who already
died on january 25th 1947 capone died
from cardiac arrest at the age of 48 he
was in his home surrounded by his loved
ones once one of the world's most
powerful and wealthy mobsters al capone
dies broke
when he was asked about how he felt
about getting convicted capone replied
publicity that's what got me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you